the wallet thanks for taking my call yes
sir I long for a friend who said a 29
year old son diagnosed with having a
neoplasm of the cranial nerve he later
saw a specialist and was told that it
was too small to operate so they want to
follow up every few months okay a
saint's neuroma yeah neoplasm of the
cream okay neoplasm okay they didn't
call it a neuroma whole game yeah
neoplasm means tumor okay cancer
neoplasm okay
and there's 12 pairs of cranial nerves
12 come out of one side 12 come on the
other side and I'm amazed if there's a
it's too small to operate okay because
usually has to be the first thing if
they find a malignancy they're gonna
take that sucker out and there'll be
side effects so you take out that
cranial nerve it hit those things okay
and so you'll lose a significant portion
of or maybe all of the function of that
nerve on that side so do you have any
idea how much this young fella waves yes
I similar info for you he's five foot
six ways to 18 and his less blood
pressure was 163 over 99 okay well he's
got high blood pressure I'm assuming
that's with medication and also he's
overweight he's obese at five foot six
I'd like the same way Oh
for a guy maybe 150 okay for even round
numbers so we're looking at 68 70 pounds
he needs to lose all right char would
you give this young fella here 29 years
old 5 foot 6 turn 18 pounds would you
give him for a small tumor we don't know
the size of a pea are great we don't
know what's going on we don't know which
nerve it is but he has high blood
pressure and he also has a neoplasm a
tumor on this cranial nerve what would
you give him to support his immune
system and deal with the high blood
pressure and also the obesity okay
charmagne again this kid is 29 years old
5 foot 660 pounds or so overweight he's
218 pounds and he has a neuro neoplasm a
small
tomber to small quote-unquote for the
doctors operate on so what did you do
for him
well I would get him on a gluten-free
diet I would get him to healthy brain
and heart packs I give him the daily
classic the nice and plus and the cardio
sticks and then I'd also give him the
oceans gold the Z radical and the
immortal iam okay well video shows go
why would you give them a thyroid
supplement to somebody with a neoplasm
who's overweight because because it's
got that sea cucumbers thank you come
brunette which is notorious for dealing
with cancer yeah supports the immune
system when people have cancer right
yeah they're wonderful wonderful
I don't dozens of studies on it and of
course what would you do again for
weight loss I get in the reve reve re v
mi go ahead and get him to droppers full
of that rev excuse me two bottles of the
dropper bottles so you take a dropper
full under his tongue 15 minutes for
each meal I'll leave it absorbs her old
tissues and and obviously take one
before that thirty minutes for each meal
the second one fifteen minutes for the
meals you can take two bottles a month
do that with a week to ten days he'll
start losing a half a pound of two
pounds a day and the magic is he'll
never gain the weight back as long as he
stays on the 90 for Life program and so
also real slowly the blood pressure
should drop because this will support
healthy blood pressure levels and he can
either gradually reduce his medication
as his doctor as educated image to do
arm he's nervous about to himself he can
actually get the doctor to lower his
medication and then give us a call every
couple of weeks
Alexander let us know this guy's weight
let us know how his blood pressure is
doing and let us know what the doctors
are saying about that